[Music]
caesar's in chicago hi cesar how are you
hey how you doing dave hi how can we
help
okay little nervous here sorry first
time caller first time listener i
discourage you remember
last summer started listening to you i
couldn't sink in into a party about a
month ago
i'm roughly a hundred and thirty
thousand dollars in debt
which is uh ninety four thousand dollars
and hopefully irs
uh i'm trying to do what i can to um
to figure out what's the best way to
tackle this
uh most of most of the other stuff is
car
car loans and credit card debt i
just went to carmax uh this weekend and
sold on a vehicle which i had some
positive equity
uh with 6500 i don't know what to do
with this money at this point
what in the world how do you owe the irs
94 000.
it's a mess i mean in 2015 and 2016 we
had a business you know
i oh i started a business with my wife
uh i pretty much try to manage the
business myself to
you know try to do everything myself and
i kind of screwed things up and didn't
help that i had a bad accounting
uh hey i contacted the irs and then
there seems to be an issue i guess we
have to file
a 1040x form uh to try to
amend those taxes uh you know but while
this is in process i mean i still have
to
you know start making some kind of
painting because i'm getting some uh
letters on the mail as far as
okay wait wait wait wait stop stop stop
stop so you're saying
that the
returns were filed improperly and you
may not actually owe this money when you
file amended returns
exactly okay but
you have you have some money you said
you had six thousand dollars from sale
your car
yes 65 i am currently on
baby step two so i got my thoughts
you're gonna spend some money right now
on a tax attorney
or a tax professional that is a stud
of some kind and um if it costs you
six thousand dollars it won't but if it
costs you two thousand dollars
this is job one right now yeah is you
can
you can take your 130 000 and wipe out
94 or a big portion of 94
with some simple proper filing you don't
do
that yourself that's how you got here
you go get a tax pro
uh check daveramsey.com and click on our
tax elps if there's not one in your area
start shopping around talk to some
business guys that are that are
competent business people in your area
ask them for advice on who
a good tax attorney or a tax pro is and
let them dig
in i don't you don't need to do anything
you don't worry about baby steps
no this is job one irs yes
job one that's what you're doing and and
cesar
make the area focused don't come up with
excuses pick up the phone call
set up a time to go sit down gather up
find out all the documents you're going
to need
because you're going to have to do
legwork here but trust me
if worth it because it's dealing with
the irs
yeah you you you're a good tax
professional
can tell you if you need to get on an
installment plan and
what level you need to do to get the
barking dogs off your heel while you get
this stuff filed
but dude you don't wait 30 seconds you
get this stuff filed
now this is an overdue term paper
and you've you know this is killing you
yeah and
these people have unlimited freaking
power
it is unbelievable what they can do to
your life if they choose to so i really
really really want them
um to go away yes i want you to get the
paperwork done
and you don't have anything that's more
important in your life for the next two
weeks other than get all of this filed
as soon as possible don't don't drag it
out three months don't drag it out two
months
file the stuff get with somebody get the
work done yeah
you stay you know get you a cup of
coffee and work into the work into the
wee hours of the morning get this done
baby
because here's the reality it's some
tweaking and the
proper filings again has the ability to
wipe some of this out this is a
this is a huge opportunity it sounds
like a good portion of it can be wiped
out it's
like they've impugned it on him because
he didn't do proper filing and they
guessed
that's right and the irs never guesses
low low
it's a rule of theirs it's written
somewhere in a book i'm sure
i've dealt with them oh god the interest
in the penalties on this stuff and it
all
goes away with properly amended filing
or a large portion of it does
yeah then get that's the stuff you
should have been working on
all these years a long time ago yes and
then once that's out of the way
you're down to just 40 000 worth of debt
now you go attack yourself
that's right